make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin okay so i want to try
something different
in this video right i want to i want to
try something new i want to try
something unique i want to
cover the first issue of dc one million
and i want to see
if you guys are interested in this right
this is one of those stories
where i only really covered if you guys
care right if you guys don't really care
i probably wouldn't really worry about
it too much but but people have been
asking me for it and so i'm curious if
it's one of those things where it's like
a ton of people really want to see it or
if people who are saying like everybody
wants to see this story if it's only
really just a couple people who actually
want to see it i'm kind of curious right
this is strictly for you guys but
dc 1 million was was really the first
major crossover following the
reformation of the jla by the justice
league of america the justice league of
america was like the second major
superhero team in comic books right the
first one was the jsa back during the
golden age it was the first real
collaboration between national allied
publications
and all-american comics right but
introducing the jla was kind of like the
top
characters at the time from dc comics
coming together on a singular team
batman and superman weren't there all
the time because dc didn't want to over
saturate the market with their
characters
but for what we saw it was exceedingly
interesting right because when
crisis on infinitives happened in 1985
the jla basically went away right dc
replaced it with justice league
international right and then we got
justice league europe that kind of a
thing in 1998 after the british invasion
uh that's when grant morrison brought
back the justice league of america team
in its self-titled series
jla and so dc one million was one of the
first major crossovers that happened as
a result of that right and so um what
this does is this initially picks up
with a guy by the name of zario now
zariel is is a character that we're
going to see off and on throughout the
story but zariel's really here because
one he was a grant morrison creation
and two because he's actually a pretty
interesting character so the way this
played out is that zarya was introduced
to
humanity more or less as a guy who would
like guard women and different things
like that you know kind of a guardian
angel of sorts created by the presence
he had his own storyline when he has uh
he had his arch nemesis which grant
morrison actually used to establish the
idea
that the presence is not like a singular
being who exists out there but the
president's is everything and everywhere
more or less is what it is
and so because that whenever you see the
presence in dc comics assuming that you
you follow grant morrison's ideology as
opposed to what we've seen
and like vertigo that when the presence
appears it's almost like
eternity from marvel right like the
coalescence of the entirety of existence
given form in a singular being this
eventually led to
the combined efforts of the jla and
zarya basically defeating zarya's
nemesis and then he was invited to join
the team which ultimately he did but
what it also deals with here is this
this idea that at some point a message
is sent out
by jon jones by the martian manhunter
essentially saying that like over a
million people are dead this is our last
message
jon jones out basically meaning whatever
it is that happened popped off right
like a million people died that's no
small thing but what we end up doing
here is basically jumping back to what's
called the first day essentially the
present day more or less or when it all
kind of kicked off
and what this does is it sort of picks
up after the jla of of the 850 for
53rd century had shown up here now
technically they're called justice
legion
a is what they refer to and we'll find
out why they're called justice legion a
but they had made sporadic appearances
over the course of the jla comics
up to this point right this is not their
first introduction they date all the way
back to i think jla number six number 12
and then 23 when we saw like several
appearances of their characters popping
up we didn't really know what the basis
was behind it we didn't really know why
they were there
it's all kind of coming to bear in this
particular story hence the reason why we
didn't really cover any of those older
one shots where they just they were just
kind of
there but what this means is that
superman and wonder woman and martian
manhunter and
and wally west and all these guys are
all basically saying like hey you know
these guys are our counterparts from the
future
now something else that i want to point
out here is that this group is also
joined by the arrival of a woman by the
name of
huntress now there have been several
characters to play the role of huntress
in dc comics the first one was helena
wayne as she originally appeared back in
1977 in dc superstar's number 17.
ultimately because of the fact that
chrysler infinite earth basically
removed the idea of the multiverse and
because of the fact that the original
helena wayne was the daughter of
catwoman and bruce wayne from an
alternate universe from earth 2 they
couldn't really use an alternate reality
counterpart to her character because
after christ on infinite earth happened
there were no alternate realities and so
under joe cavallari she was basically
rebooted in her entirety and she was
introduced as a woman named helena
bertinelli uh she's the daughter of
maria burton nelly but anyway um she was
basically rewritten as that character to
some you know to kind of be a little
more in line with her original origins
but you've also got a couple familiar
faces here right you've got john henry
irons as steel he was a member of the
jla that basically stayed on after the
events of the death and return of
superman you've also got kyle rainer
who's currently the green lantern of
course a lot of you guys know that
following the events of emerald twilight
but what you basically have is this
853rd
century version of the justice league of
america and for the most part it's kind
of interesting the way they function
right because the jla does not
immediately trust them right off the bat
right this group shows up hey guys we're
you like we're your counterparts from
like the 853rd century you have to
believe us and it's not like they're
kind of like okay
cool bro like awesome good to have you
aboard because one of the things they
talk about
is how the technology and the various
weapons and resources and things like
that that are available to the jla are
something that's coveted by
a lot of people who are out there right
and a lot of people will do whatever
they can
in order to get in there and take a lot
of those resources right these weapons
could lay waste to entire cities and
even uh lay waste to the justice league
themselves and so as a result of this
they kind of put them through these sort
of mental scans right to verify their
authenticity to make sure these guys are
legit and they are right they you know
they kind of come back
and and basically reveal yeah you know
these guys are okay everything's on the
up and up wally west basically vouches
for the speedster from his time period
kind of a funny thing um the speedster
as he exists now this version of the
flash
is not actually from the 853rd century
instead
he's from the uh from the the 27th
century i think it is and then was
actually time displaced in the 853rd
century and then stayed there but what
you end up having is this
you know essentially this revelation
that in the 853rd century
the legacy of the justice league of
america has lasted that long but the
notion that
that in this future time period the
legacy still lives on
really comes to fruition in a lot of
different ways right what's happened
here is that in this time period the
entirety of our solar system has been
completely colonized right it's been
rebuilt and it's been totally colonized
humans are living on various planets
around the solar system and it's one of
these things where humanity
and really society as a whole seems to
have reached this kind of golden age
right this age of enlightenment and
exploration
and so because that things are
infinitely better now it wasn't without
its struggles right that what there was
at some point in time
is there was a being by the name of
solaris right who was essentially a
super intelligent
supercomputer that was powered by proton
fusion processors is how they explain it
but essentially he's been repurposed
into a second sun and the reason why is
because somewhere along the line the
superman of the 505th century actually
died reversing the programming of
solaris and then in turn
having solaris basically orbit is is
kind of a protective system
as well as a second sun for the solar
system and so with that being the case
humanity's kind of
gone on to experience this this era of
exploration this era of technology and
science but one of the cool things to
come out of this is what's referred to
as
the superman dynasty in the sense that
you have this kind of legacy where
superman had
you know presumably all these different
offspring but the dynasty really points
to the idea that superman really is the
greatest of all the superheroes
so the whole reason why the the the
justice legion is here and that was kind
of the big question that jla had right
like it's one thing
for us to verify you're here from the
85th 53rd century it's another for us to
know why and their response is because
superman prime is coming back right the
prime superman is making his return that
he had essentially
kind of traveled around the cosmos we
don't really know what he did but he
traveled
around the cosmos then he eventually
came back and settled in the sun he's
been there ever since and now he's
leaving the sun and he's basically
coming back to earth this is a huge time
of celebration and that's really what
this is it's supposed to be a gigantic
celebration for the return
of superman prime and that's kind of
what blows superman away in the present
day because it's him and that's kind of
what knocks his socks off he's like wait
you're telling me that i'm alive
in the year 85 271 and like i'm in the
sun and i'm coming back
it's kind of a shocker for a couple
different reasons one because he gets
this revelation he's alive in that time
period and two
it's kind of sad because what it means
is he's outlived everyone he cares about
multiple lifetimes over and over again
but following this what we do is we
switch over to oracle now this is one of
the one of those moments in dc comics
and we talked about this when we cover
the various members of the bat family
this is one of those eras in dc comics
when a lot of people loved batgirl the
most right we're not really bad girl but
barbara gordon they loved her the most
and the reason why is because after alan
moore's the killing joke when she was
paralyzed while that story was not
originally in continuity eventually it
was made to be in continuity and so with
barbara gordon basically being paralyzed
kind of going forward from there a lot
of the questions that people had
is what's dc gonna do with her character
and what they did is they totally
reworked her and made her kind of like
this information
hub for not only just the members of the
bat family but also like the justice
league and various other people out
there who all would kind of go to her
and say
i need information i need somebody to
tap into these back channels and get me
info on this and info on that and that
kind of a thing and so as a result she
became an exceedingly cool character the
other part of this is that
arsenal is trying to reform the titans
now we'll talk about why that matters uh
here in a second but at the moment
you've essentially got nightwing kind of
carrying on this mantle and you know
doing his patrol
but you've got some cool little some
cool little references right some cool
little moments but what we end up doing
here is basically jumping back to uh to
the jla having this conversation with
the
with the justice legion a and then
basically learning that like
representatives from
all the worlds across the saul system
are all going to be there to pay tribute
multiple
superman and super women from across the
entirety of existence right like the
justice legionnaires from like the very
far-flung future
all these people are going to be here to
witness the return of superman prime so
again this is a huge deal and so from
there it's really kind of a question of
is anybody going to go right like who's
going to attend this who's going to be
there and for for a lot of these folks
it's kind of like this is cool right
because there's going to be these kind
of gladiatorial games you know different
things along those lines and these kind
of arenas this really like appeals to
aquaman you know he's kind of like yeah
like i'm down with that you know and
wonder woman in a lot of the same way
but all in all everybody's on board with
this right you know like kyle rainer and
superman wonder woman everybody's
basically on board
the only person who we haven't really
heard from here is batman
is bruce wayne and of course helena
wayne's the one that shows up to kind of
drop some of these tidbits of
information but of course as usual
batman's already for the most part kind
of aware but it's one of these cool
things because batman's kind of been
dismissive
of of huntress and a lot of the reason
is because of the fact that like he
doesn't really like her methods but at
the same time she's also pretty
effective at what she does and so it's
better to have her there than to like
have her out there doing whatever and
and things kind of being
all over the place but one of the funny
situations about this is that batman's
like you can't really cheat everybody
like they're an enemy like they're
inherently bad people but the response
of huntress is but they usually
are she's really kind of distrustful
doesn't really believe in any kind of
any kind of like goodness in people but
one of the things that happens is when
he shows up in the batcave he's
immediately met by the arrival of batman
from 800 from the 853rd century now we
don't really know much about this guy at
this point in time
and even batman himself kind of asks a
few questions and he's kind of like why
did you choose the bat and the response
of batman 1 million is i'll tell you at
some future point in time but what he
basically says is you have to go you
have to attend this thing bruce wayne
doesn't really want to go right it's not
really in his interest to go there
because he's kind of like i mean
like i care about what's going on right
now i don't care about what's going on
in some far-flung future the result of
this is that you know batman 1 million
basically
takes him he launches a kind of attack
that hits both physically and
telepathically and he basically says by
the time you realize this sentence is
going on for far too long you'll realize
that huntress was right this is all
gonna be over and it's all gonna be done
and then you're gonna be with me so
literally he just seems to take the
essence of batman with him a spirit in a
bottle in quite a literal sense and
that's basically it
from there we learned a few other things
right we basically learned that there
were like these these coral cities and
underwater pirate kingdoms on neptune
that the women of the mascara had
colonized
venus you know in the 800th century so
like these are the kind of things that
sort of drive them there it's one thing
to know that superman prime is coming
back and it's cool to be part of that
celebration but it's also kind of piqued
their interests in terms of like what's
this future like like what kind of
things are there you kind of get this
cool moment where wonder woman basically
reveals her invisible jet which is a
really good
really good return for a lot of people
who were really kind of nostalgic for an
era of comics that they were not a part
of which happens right you know we as
comic book fans
we think about eras like the 1940s or
the 1950s and comics and we were never
really a part of it i mean some of us
were but most of us
like 99 of us were not but we're still
kind of nostalgic for that era
for a lot of fans who had seen like the
return of wonder woman's uh invisible
jet post crisis a lot of people liked
that right it was a way to kind of
recapture that old school you know those
old school comics and just kind of go
from there and so following that you
basically have the entirety of the
of the justice league who basically
assemble alongside the justice legion a
for the purpose of course meeting at
mount rushmore and then beginning the
process of being sent to the future
right that it's not something they don't
just like snap their fingers and go
you've got to kind of manipulate the
time stream to a degree you got to be
careful you got to make sure you send
them back and they don't end up inside
of like a giant cinder
uh you know a brick wall or something
along those lines so like you can't just
arbitrarily send them right you got to
make sure that everything's in order and
everything's lined up but what we end up
doing here is we end up switching over
to
mongolia and the reason why is here in
northern mongolia there's basically kind
of a weapons system a weapons event
that's going down but what you have here
is you have arsenal you have tempest and
you have supergirl and this is basically
kind of the reformation of the titans
now
one of the things that i held off
mentioning here is that huntress was
designed to be a replacement for oliver
queen and the reason why is oliver queen
was killed in 1995 i think it was
in green arrow issue number 101 right so
he had been removed now ultimately he
was brought back in 2001 2002
uh in in green arrow quivers but at the
moment he's basically
dead and so what it did is it really
kind of came down to arsenal sort of
picking up the mantle of oliver queen
and continuing on
albeit trying to reform the teen titans
and basically going from there that's
why you see tempest here that's why you
see supergirl is being a part of this
but the person that we also see here
that's
arriving on the scene is vandal savage
now vandal savage is here
because what's happening is there's
these rocket red suits that are being
auctioned off
now the idea of the rocket red suits was
originally introduced in 1987 as part of
the green lantern comics uh so they're
post crisis and if i'm if i'm a vetting
man
i would say they were kind of in in some
ways dc's answer to like iron man
because what it did is it allowed
individuals to enter the suit and then
in turn
basically have like you know
invulnerability and the ability to fly
to shoot like these super powerful
energy blasts different things like that
a lot of it really seemed to be based on
iron man tech but in some ways you know
it's also based on on concepts that
existed before marvel really became a
major thing right like old school dc
characters and plus
existing dc characters right red tornado
stuff like that so these suits were
modeled after a few different concepts
but four of them
are currently being auctioned off
because if they're taken by these
nefarious individuals they could be used
for a variety of different purposes but
vandal savage basically shows up here
and and essentially
states he's willing to pay three billion
dollars in order to buy all four of
these things which is a huge sum of cash
now for those of you guys who know
vandal savage is exceedingly old he's
immortal he's been around for
thousands and thousands and thousands of
years right and so because of that uh
he's one of these guys that has the
resources to pull it off but it's also
some you know part of some nefarious
plan that he has
and the reason for that is because ever
since his introduction with vandal
savage's age
he never creates any kind of schemes or
plans that will come to fruition in like
a matter of weeks or months right that
never happens
vandal savage plans for decades and
centuries because he knows he's immortal
so he'll start the seeds of a plan today
that won't come to fruition until like 4
000 years from now his longevity allows
him to become this kind of
chess grand master in like the game of
strategic social and political warfare
on a regular basis right it makes him
exceedingly capable and so knowing that
vandal savage is here he's a guy who's
basically a justice league level threat
that the titans are trying to face off
against and a lot of this is because roy
harper you know arsenal kind of wants to
prove that he's just as capable as green
arrow but that the titans can be just as
capable as the jla which is
going to be kind of a major problem
they're going to run into because as
soon as that happens of course you have
the arrival of jesse quick now jesse
quick was introduced in the
really the justice society of america
volume 2 in 1992 in the first issue and
the reason why is because again because
the the jsa
was an alternate reality version of the
justice league before the justice league
what it meant was that post-crisis
because there was no more multiverse
you couldn't have a jsa from a different
reality and so what this meant is dc
came back and basically reworked their
origin
and established the idea that the jsa
was essentially a superhero team that
existed
during world war ii right and so what
this did is it allowed for the
introduction of jesse chambers or jesse
quick as a character who was the the
daughter of johnny quick and johnny
quick was one of the one of the
speedsters back before crisis on
infinite earth and post-crisis who used
a mathematical formula to achieve super
speed the difference here is that where
barry allen was doused by chemicals and
struck by lightning wally west wanted
the same thing
max mercury got his powers from a native
american shaman that with
johnny chambers and these guys and his
daughter jesse quick basically sang a
mathematical proof
these were all completely separate
methods of achieving super speed it
wasn't until the introduction of the
speed force and mark wade's terminal
velocity that we basically learned they
were all tapping into the speed force
right that's how they all managed to
gain access to it but nonetheless that's
why she's able to do what she does
she's not the not the fastest speedster
there ever was but with a lack of barry
allen with wally west currently on the
jla it does present the opportunity for
them to have someone with super speed on
their side which is really an invaluable
asset in the realm of the superhero and
supervillain community and the issue
with this is that for all the pomp and
circumstance of having a speedster on
their team
jessie quick is still pretty
inexperienced but she's also dealing
with a guy who's been around for an
exceedingly long time and who knows
almost everything there is to know about
speedsters and so essentially
he picked up immediately on the fact
that the titans are here that roy harper
and his guys are here just by of course
having his scouts monitoring things and
so on and so forth but he's also
developed a way to essentially overcome
speedsters
now supergirl is currently here as well
as somebody who essentially infiltrated
the group of
vandal savage which he allowed her to do
of course supergirl only being a
temporary member of the team at the
moment but what happens here is that as
soon as the titans launch their attack
the vandal savage invented a device or
has a device that basically emits a
signal
that is not really able to be heard by
the average person but for a person
traveling at super speed it's absolutely
devastating right and so
that immediately takes out jessie quick
from there you've got roy harper who
fires the neural scrambler arrow which
vandal savage catches and then throws at
supergirl and takes her out
that's how this all goes down each one
of these guys are systematically taken
out by vandal savage
one after another after another after
another that's what makes him so
dangerous he's a one-man
wrecking crew he's just so capable and
he's so experienced and so because of
that you know with basically all the
different
all the different members of the of the
team being taken out they're all
essentially put
inside of these rocket red suits more or
less to you know seemingly be controlled
by vandal savage or to carry out
whatever his mission happens to be and
so what this does is it leads to the jla
totally unaware of all this
is that that's going on essentially
being sent to the future by the justice
legion a right you know jumping back to
this group right here
once they're sent to the future they
arrive seemingly to where they believe
they're supposed to be or at least that
seems to be the case the issue with this
is that the justice legion a is supposed
to travel there as well as soon as
that's supposed to happen
our man who's the one that's enabling
this whole process is completely and
totally corrupted and literally he just
kind of breaks down and then collapses
right and so what this means is that the
jla of the present day
is stuck in the 853rd century and the
justice legion a
is stuck in the modern day and so kind
of you know jumping to the 853rd century
we end up finding out
that all of this has been orchestrated
by vandal savage and this is why i say
this is the nature of vandal savage it's
85 000 years into the future
and he's still alive and he looks like
he's only really aged by maybe
20 years right so it's kind of weird
you'd expect him to be the same age
forever either that or he decided to
grow his hair out and give himself some
white streaks which is kind of cool
because he looks pretty awesome he just
looks
menacing man like if i saw somebody like
that walking down the street i'd
probably think one of two things
either that guy's a pimp or that guy's
like the most dangerous person
in the world right just like some
criminal mastermind but nonetheless
we end up finding out that the solaris
sun hit his essentially seemed to have
kind of
gone back to its programming of being a
villain right it didn't take too kindly
to being reprogrammed by superman from
the 505th century and so essentially
solaris alongside vandal savage are
working together to essentially ensure
that when superman prime shows up that
he has to watch his counterparts die
from the modern day right that's kind of
their their grand scheme is to destroy
the jla now we are going to see
a litany of things take place besides
this and there's a lot more going on
between
with regards to solaris and vandal
savage behind the scenes but let me know
if you guys want to see more of this
right let me know if you guys want to
see more of this this uh dc 1 million
i'm kind of curious but if you guys are
new here to commerce explained
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob core if you guys
enjoy this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
[Music]
peace
[Music]
so
[Music]
you